joining me uh right now to kick off our
second hour here on peacock
is uh somebody who i'm thrilled to be
able to call
a friend and also another coach turned
broadcaster terrific in his own right
spending uh the last
eight years i believe sitting on the nfl
network draft set well with us when
there's
not a pandemic stanford head coach of
the football program there
david shaw how are you coach i'm great
rich how are you man better for talking
to you
how's your family everybody okay good
well i hope uh
everybody's doing really well we're safe
kids are about to start their online
school again and we are all huge monk
fans so i'm
excited about tonight yeah that's it
david well done and when you know i mean
download peacock if you already haven't
when you can watch it uh
whenever you whenever you want when
you're not uh i already have it i
already downloaded it
i love it coach you're you know what
there is an eye on david but you are
definitely a team player when it comes
to the rich eisen show
so let's uh let's talk about what's
going on um
in in your in your world there's so many
ways to approach
uh what's going on with pac-12 football
i will just come straight through the
front door
uh with you first and ask if you agreed
with the pac-12 decision to
move off of the fall season
unequivocally
um i absolutely agree and i'm one of the
fortunate ones
i was part of the patchwork working
group and also
i was also in the nba working group
we talked a lot about these issues so i
was able to see the entire progression
and
a lot of people forget we all started
with the process way back in march
april with two questions can we do this
and should we do this
um and we got to the point where it was
really hard to answer
both of those questions as the season
was rapidly approaching
so then let me flip the equation and ask
the question of you
that so many fans of big ten football
are asking
and nebraska parents are asking and head
coaches of football programs there
have intimated why can't we do this
let me flip it and ask you that way so
i'll
i'll rattle off the top six things
one and the one that shocked and it
really hurt kind of hurt our entire
process was
this potential for the heart abnormality
and
for us to not have a clear and concise
and definite
answer about how this virus
can affect your heart short term and
long term
was really hard for a lot of some of
these world-renowned
cardiologists to answer right we're
finding different things about this
virus
at all times every single week seems
like something else pops up oh we've got
this now it's this
and this is one of those things we
always talk about you know the brain and
the heart
we have to be extra cautious besides
that
we are operating under an assumption
that
these masks helmet shields and our
testing pro
process is going to keep the virus out
um unless you create a bubble you can't
see providers out
it's it's our our student athletes in
particular
engage with society they engage on their
on their campuses
um it's hard to completely sequester
them um
and and the college uh college sport
because we're not just talking about
football we're also talking about all
the fall sports
um and and the testing thing which is
combined with what i just said but then
also a separate piece
we can't do what the nfl is doing which
is test every single student athlete in
every single sport
every single day from now through the
entire fall semester
that is a really really difficult thing
the last thing for me is a quote that's
not my quote that i heard two doctors
quoted so i don't know who to give the
credit to so i'll just say it
i said the worst thing to do in a
pandemic is take a large group of people
from one area
to another area engage in physical
activity with another large group
and then return to your original area
regardless of sports
that is a difficult thing to conceive
and do
with a virus that has not slowed down or
stopped
in the last six months david shaw
stanford university head football coach
here on the rich eisen show
okay so having heard that and said that
um why
are three other power five conferences
still moving ahead
do you think i can't answer it per se
i do know a lot of people both
commissioners athletic directors
coaches etc a lot of these places and
i they are doing everything they can and
many of us were as well like you are
testing student athletes
we all believe the best place for these
our student athletes is with us
everyone has said that repeatedly and i
agree with that 100
the hard part now is to say can we
without without a shadow of a doubt
create an
environment to where we can travel
participate in games
practice engage in society engage on our
campuses
and tell our student athletes and their
parents
that we are doing something that's right
for them because the other
big part of this too is there are a lot
of people involved it's not just a
student athlete
you've got coaches you've got trainers
you've got doctors you've got equipment
personnel
you've got all kinds of people that it
takes to run
a a a a football team
and those people are at risk as well
and so it's not just the 18 to 22 year
olds that
for the most part there are some
exceptions for the most part
can handle the virus et cetera but there
are a lot of people that are
closer to you and if age that don't hand
it out the virus as well
and god forbid a young person ends up
being thrown on a ventilator as
it happened a few times two different
places got the dead
a trainer a coach someone else
associated with a with a
sports team contracted virus and dies
like that's a hard thing to say that
it's worth it that we can't put it off
that we can't give these young people
eligibility back look at playing either
in the winter or in the spring or
even looking to follow 21 and say let's
do this and we'll have more answers
but be a little bit safer the students
will for most people
not just the student athletes but
everybody associated can operate with a
little bit more certainty
that it takes so do you think david shaw
when it all comes out um
in the fall football wash whenever that
might be
that the acc sec and big 12 will
eventually come to the same conclusion
that your conference in the big ten have
already come to
i believe one of two things is going to
happen one is there is a chance
that whether it's the ncaa board of
directors um
dr heinlein who is the chief medical
officer for the ncaa
has said multiple times the last couple
weeks and once on your show
that the the path is extremely narrow
it's extremely narrow for fall sports
this year with the virus that continues
to raise continue to rage
on college campuses repeatedly are
opening and cleveland
within a week um sending people away
quarantining people
um the path is extremely narrow so
either someone or the director-wise
someone
at the conference level looks and just
says we've been operating at high level
and doing this really well but we can't
see competition happening
or they continue and
we still miss multiple games we still
have
young men and their families at some
point in the season saying hey you know
what this isn't worth it we're
we're opting out and you will have a
disrupted suit and maybe
some teams won't but a good portion of
teams are going to have
much like it's happened multiple times
this past the past two weeks
you might be gearing up for a game and a
university
or a college team shuts down and you
lose your game
um so that was a lot of fears with our
guys too what kind of a season would we
have if we did have a season
scheduled to play ten would we play six
would we play five
would i lose my eligibility would it be
worth it
those are those are questions that are
really hard to answer on the front end
of this season
stanford university had football coach
david shaw here on the rich eisen show a
couple more minutes on this topic
so let's talk process because it sure
sounds like
uh my my football coach who you know
well and jim harbaugh
ryan day james franklin in the big ten
obviously
uh scott frost in nebraska
felt a little bit uh blindsided by the
big ten's decision
did the pac-12 reach out to you guys and
in your positions and give you a heads
up that
apparently it seems like the big ten did
not with their football coach why are we
not seeing essentially
the same issues in pac-12 country that
we're seeing in big ten country
about the cancellation or post moment
first of all those guys that you
mentioned i know very well ryan dude
just met this past year have a lot of
respect for him
i believe these guys are doing it
they're doing a great job and doing it
the right way um all i can do is say
what our conference
once again i was in the working group
and we met with the coaches each week
so the working group might have that two
or three times a week we brought the
coaches in and gave them updates
every single week so the coaches knew
the process they knew when it was
looking good they knew when it wasn't
looking good and many times
it was looking good one week and not as
good the next week so we were able to
communicate the ups and downs throughout
this time
and there was a suggestion that hey
continue to keep your
student athletes updated let them know
where we are
like we know that this this we're
excited about the possibility but we're
not
sure we can get it done so um there was
a lot of communication with our coaches
and their athletic directors and their
director football operations people
um really pretty much non-stop from
about
april through last week
and then i guess just pushing it forward
what pathway do you see right now and
obviously in your answer that you just
delivered coach shaw
um whether you say one week it looked
good another one it didn't it's so
difficult to predict we have no earthly
idea
how the virus is gonna play out so
what about winter i mean we're already
hearing in the big ten
and ryan day um along with justin fields
saying let's play uh now is justin field
saying that but
talking about a a january start but
let's try then
how does that look do you what's your
idea of a pathway to that
right now well first of all you said
that nobody really knows
i think it would be great i think we'd
have to do it with some common sense
um the later we start the shorter the
season has to be in my opinion
in order to not adversely affect the
fall of 21.
um so as much as we all would want to
play
the reason why we had the 10 game season
instead of a 12 game
that play in january i think we need to
truncate a little bit and just
think about um they've got to have a
full season and have a national
championship
um because now you try to have a full
season starting in january
they're going to play until march april
may
and now how do you truly get your guys
back and ready
for training camp in august that's a
hard question to answer our medical
professionals will have to weigh in
there
we've got decades upon decades of
data as far as what this sport does to
the human body
and we've got to have a reasonable
expectation to get our young people back
by training camp of august so my perfect
world
if we can do this if the virus
cooperates if we find answers for this
heart
issue is to say okay we start in january
and we end no later than the beginning
of march
play the truncated season have
conference championship games
and then call of the day the ncaa has
already said if we do play it's not
going to affect your eligibility
so some of those guys if you had a short
season some of those guys would have
enough film
jump into the draft at april which i
can't wait to be on the desk with you
hopefully that happens next april
for the draft uh and then everybody else
if they finish in march
you can make a reasonable case that they
can have some down time
start to train and be ready for training
camp in august
last one for you coach uh one year ago
today i don't know if you're aware of
this but it was one year ago today
andrew luck stepped to a podium in
indianapolis and made the rumor official
that he was no longer
going to play football he was going to
retire when was the last time you spoke
to andrew luck uh we've texted multiple
times
spoke to him a few weeks ago sounds
great
um you know i've talked to people before
where
they're just that great place in their
lives and that's where he is
um he's got a baby girl he's grown fast
uh he's absolutely adorable he's got an
unbelievable wife
um he's he's had a great career um
still thinking about what phase two for
him is
understands how people can feel about
one way or another about how he stepped
away and when he stepped away and why he
stepped away
but he knows in his heart he did the
right thing
you've talked to athletes over the years
that have played these sports for so
long no one knows how their bodies feel
um they put it off they get a mindset
but they fight through it they fight
through it they love their teammates
andrew loves to compete he wants to be
the best
and it came to a point to where he
couldn't do it anymore and walked away
for his health and his family and i
couldn't be more proud of him
and um you know you're right when you
hear somebody like that
you you understand a little bit more and
a little bit better
do you think he's done with public life
though do you think he's done with a
football life
period david uh that's a great question
um as with so many great athletes
andrew's athleticism and his ability to
throw a football were
phenomenal but they weren't the best
part of who he was
or who he is so we'll see
i don't know if he'll do any tv i don't
know what he'll do but
he's so engaging he's so great with
people
um he's so he's so smart and he's got
the mind of an engineer
so we'll see where it leads and i would
love for him to be
somewhere doing something publicly
because the more people talk to him they
realize that he is
an outstanding human being that i think
can add a lot to our society
well coach i appreciate that as you know
having sat next to me for many years i
love hearing that's a great question
said to me so i appreciate that and
since you're an excellent arbiter of
what a great question sounds like
uh do you have one for tony shalhoub as
a monk fan
that i can forward to him at the top of
my third hour do you got one
for me to ask him yeah he's such a great
character actor
um the the he's so great at monk
and at the same time so great in in
mizell yes so i'm wondering if the two
characters have
if there's something that resonates with
both of them okay because it does such a
great job of getting into those people
um i wonder if there's any connection or
if they're completely different
expertise
that's a great question right back at
you coach shaw
round of applause for david shaw thanks
for calling i'm a fan i'm a fan
i've actually been awesome yeah he was
great and men in black
um he's been great in a bunch of things
he is amazing that's why he's a he's an
award winner uh thanks
thanks for the call coach you take care
of yourself best your family let's uh
stay in touch
we'll chat soon absolutely thanks rick
you got it that's david shaw hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here